president biden's press secretary
jensachi joins us now from the white
house
jen good morning thanks for being with
us morning thank you the white house is
calling this uh child tax credit
awareness
day and we want to talk about that in
just a minute but i want to
get your comments on some of the
reporting that we just heard from chris
about the bipartisan deal on
infrastructure will the president
support this deal
well first let me say we need a few more
details about the deal and about the
proposal including specifics about how
to pay
for it an idea that's been floating
around there that certainly the
president would not support
is a gas tax which would raise taxes on
people making less than 400 000
a year we're just not going to stand for
that and we're not going to accept that
it is a positive sign though that
democrats and republicans are continuing
to negotiate
the president looks forward to getting
more details he'll probably be talking
to welcoming some members to the white
house over the next couple of days
and we'll go from there so the president
is willing to talk about this
what is he willing to compromise on well
he's already come down quite a bit
and in his initial proposal from his
initial number so
that's a sign that he's willing to
compromise he's also looking to work on
a couple of tracks so
i know during the earlier reporting you
talked about our commitment to climate
change or what we're going to do about
that
addressing the big issues this country
is facing the president agrees with
senator sanders we need to address those
as well
there's a reconciliation process that's
also moving forward at the same time
but i think the question here is what
can we agree on democrats and
republicans
can we rebuild our roads our railways
and our bridges the president is eager
to continue those discussions and see if
we can make big progress this week
jen you're calling this child tax credit
awareness day because starting on july
15th
uh families will be eligible for up to
300 a month in advance on their taxes
uh in support of their children uh the
president has said he wants to make that
not permanent but available for years
and years
i guess the first question is is does
that mean permanent
and how would he plan to get there
either permanent or for years
well let me first say we're making this
child tax credit awareness day because
there are
millions of people who are eligible
around the country for this
and they may not know they're eligible
so they can go to child tax credit
dot gov and find out if they're eligible
sign up and get these benefits which are
going to start going out
every month to americans on july 15th
the president has proposed to extend it
by five years
and he's open to having a conversation
with congress with members about
what more they want to do because he
thinks this is a central benefit that
will help families
help get women back to work um over a
million have left the workforce
during the pandemic so he's going to
continue to fight for this and he's
proposed extending it in his american
family's plan
would he like to see it made permanent
look i think there's a there's a central
cost here it costs
money of course to make this permanent
he wants to see it extended by five
years
he thinks that would be a positive step
forward and he's certainly open to
talking with congress about how we can
work together on
continuing to get this benefit out to
families across the country
jen as chris vancleve mentioned a vote
is expected as early as tuesday
on sweeping voting rights reform that
bill
is looking to come up short of the 60
votes it needs
if it does fail what is the president's
next move on this
well let me just say that voting rights
making it more accessible
easier to vote is not just a one-week
process or one-week commitment by the
president
this is going to be a cause of his
presidency and yes i wouldn't say we
expect there to be 10 magical votes to
appear
from the republicans in the senate
they've been pretty clear that they
don't want to make it easier to vote
they don't want to make it more
accessible to vote
so this is just a first step we'll see
where it goes we'll see what happens
over the next couple of days
the president's asked his vice president
his partner
to lead this effort over the coming
months and expect she and he will
continue to be out there
in states working with legislators to
see how we can work together on
making it more accessible for people
across the country jen zaki from the
white house this morning thank you jen
we appreciate it